the commissioners today adopted a
communication on the secure fifth
generation mobile network deployment
within our European Union with this
communication the Commission endorses
the toolbox that member states have
jointly agreed upon we can do great
things with 5g it will be a major
enabler for future digital services in
core areas of every citizens lives the
technology supports personalized
medicine precision agriculture enables
energy grids that can integrate all
different kinds of renewable energy
this will make a positive difference we
can achieve the goals that we have set
ourselves but only if we can make our
networks secure only then will digital
changes benefit every citizen the
Commission will support the
implementation of the EU approach to 5g
cybersecurity by working to ensure a
diverse and sustainable 5g supply chain
for example via the application of the
foreign direct investment screening
trades defense instruments competition
rules to make sure there's no lock-in as
well as through EU funding program and
their security conditionality
furthermore the commission will
facilitate coordination among member
states on standardization and EU wide
certification
both our communication and the EU
toolbox are based on an objective
assessment of risk and a balanced set of
possible measures they apply across the
board and do not target any specific
country or company at the same time we
know that the decisions of the European
Union and its member states will take
the decision that we will take will that
will matter and have an impact in the
way that we relate to our partners and
we want of course to tackle this head-on
in an open and a frank manner that's
Angie said too energetic John Pitman
well I'm a clear telecommunication
Hickey Bob washer a always on the move
and Waddell even got coop at the party
not reconvene the p2 Shepherd to
citizenship to you the transfer
separates the residency to save Edom of
a twenty possible
PAH The Diplomats Angie he be the most
easily mo concern do not hold the super
intelligence ability Zeta a cigarette
Impala can elicit a mom so so me on
somebody but only la clínica de
communication wobbu seeker koshered
report on poor in the primary demo the
the technology in avail taken say
consequently at least we know that's a
drama solace Oct 2013 9 video cordially
yes
it's not restrict it's not necessary go
be so busy justice that she could show
the kita objective should auditory kita
objective the coconut are you can see
resume like emission migrate mmmm meaty
coke
DFK a travel set approach the
communication was doggedly or similar
tell you tell pay either we tell su CT
sleep and a travel pillow asleep alcohol
and wash on at v-- game Georgia log
sang-gui
CUDA module avec little knob will evolve
a game as cassette communication back to
the box telecommunication T bar back
seat communication key verses Killaloe
Tom it all told Allison C do need that
disability a to receptor altogether
eight strategic and eleven technical
measures are identified together with
the ten supporting actions which will
help member states and the Union to
ensure the cybersecurity of by three
networks for the benefit of the citizens
and society the main aim of these
measures is reinforcing security in
design deployment and operations of
networks raising baseline security
standards for the security of products
and services minimizing the exposure to
risk stemming from the risk profile of
individual suppliers avoiding or
limiting major dependencies on any
single supplier in 5g networks and
promoting a diverse competitive and
sustainable market for 5g equipment
including by maintaining new capacities
in the 5g value chain in line with
there are national risk assessments
member states will use the measures and
medication plans in efficient way to
address existing security gaps
especially concerning the strengthening
of security requirements for mobile
operators and suppliers it is important
to maintain a diverse and sustainable 5g
supply chain avoiding dependency on only
one supplier in the implementation of
mitigation plans at national level the
member state will also need to access to
assess whether they need to cooperate
with other member states or at the EU
level some strategic measures may also
require specific legislation at national
level in order to fully achieve the
impact of the measures